[Music]
[Applause]
it's hot
here's why so many people are out today
is because eric boss is getting married
tomorrow um if you
follow my twitter send them some love a
bunch of us are about to get on planes
after this and go to chicago um i was
about to say but if you're watching
right now there's a reason the four of
us are doing the show and the rest of
the people are gone we weren't invited
no we bury him
his urn will
go on the break room set
sorry disappointing jolene in the chat
i'm trying to be funny today and it's
not working for some of you welcome back
to the break room our daily show that
keeps you updated on all nerdy news you
need to know about today coming up on
the show we're talking about some
aquaman being a comedy
funnier than me
we also got black
we also get black ada answering the big
questions uh no spider-man allowed in
she-hulk that's christine but also
understandable plus someone here is a
red flag oh we're gonna figure that out
the shirt ain't helping this shirt is a
lot more worried about it are you
working at target not today speaking of
the target employee with the best we got
we got my boy eric hey how are you doing
internet
what's your shirt
this is my foray in the comedy it's my
college sketch comedy group at the
university of maryland college park
it's so thin not as funny as aquaman
i don't like the name though
that is really fun my sketch uh name in
college was uh generation friends oh
that's fun not as fun as sketchup we got
john john costa on the board i don't
know what to do with this now
what do you want
to put it over
hi everybody i wasn't in a sketch group
in college but i wish i was so i'm
jealous because i don't have any
anniversaries to celebrate with lulls oh
well we have some anniversaries today
anniversaries of eating things
for every 100 that we get today you guys
in redemptions and super chats we you
guys will get to well you get to choose
which of us will be playing what's in
the box or egg roulette it's in the box
what's in the box i don't know if you
can see it right here but in front of us
we have four mystery boxes don't hold it
up because you'll know you can't shake
them shake them oh oops there's things
inside uh where you guys have seen us
play this before we punch inside the box
and whatever's in that box we're eating
i don't care if we crush it i don't care
if we break it i don't care if it's
taped up spaghetti that zach had two
weeks ago it's tommy's chest hair no no
there's still some leftovers
edibles are all food edibles and then
maybe we would rather do egg roulette
and egg roulette is when we're going to
crack an egg over our head in front of
you guys and seven of these eggs are not
boiled
so that's oh they're sitting in it yeah
so five are uncooked so one of these
eggs will definitely
break off and roll down our clean
clothes our beautiful dresses our
sketchup shirts oh god you're poor
sketchup shirt can't get that again yeah
nope
one more time edition so if we do if we
do reach a hundred dollars in the super
chats we will figure out who gets to
break this open and eat whatever's
inside or just crack an egg on our head
because we're a couple of eggheads
i love it maybe it's a cake maybe it's a
shoe maybe some spaghetti from two weeks
ago maybe it's inedible it's uh a
different afternoon
send your shoes send your super chats in
if we break five hundred dollars today
i'll smash all the rocks in my head that
we didn't get to oh
[Laughter]
let's get wet let's get wet uh kicking
us off yucca prieta i don't know send us
uh oh i'm sorry j master yucca prieta
thank you so much for your super chat
but this is what i want to get to j
master sent us a five dollar super chat
unconfirmed they're claiming who knows
breaking news warner brothers discovery
is considering canceling teen titan uh
and doom patrol on hbo max
uh
we can't confirm that we're not going to
talk about it today but if that's true
you heard it here second
um but we did get some news there's a
great gq article that came out this week
of profiling jason momoa and he's
talking about aquaman two he says it's a
lot funnier than the first one um in the
context for that i have no idea about um
what a wild thing to say who needs
comedy uh that's what we have the mcu
for uh he does say uh he was like
tripping over his words a little bit
here he says um
i have a great time with there's a lot
of it's a throwback too and then he
finally gets to a sentence he says i
don't want to give too much away but we
get really up to speed with what's going
to happen to this earth and it's not
because of aliens he said these
superhero movies dot this is this is
what i thought was really interesting
too he said these superhero movies
dominate our market which i have my own
thoughts on because i love cinema
but we try to put out a positive message
and go on an adventure that's a little
weird that he's like is he throwing
shade at superhero movies i can't tell
while also
he's like he's like if they're gonna do
them i'm gonna participate uh but then i
guess to the comedy side of it all he
says sort of aquaman is the most made
fun of superhero in the world but it's
amazing to be able to bring awareness of
what's happening to our planet it's not
some story that's been told over and
over um but a movie about what's
happening right now but in a fantasy
world so yeah a couple things you can
kind of take from that right like
maybe they're gonna be poking fun at
aquaman as a character in the movie and
that's where some of the humor comes
from jeez louise we just got a
ridiculous super chat oh wow um
i don't even it's finish the week strong
trash emoji trash
emoji thank you tanisha
maisie i can't read that's far away
everything's far away uh okay
the poll is starting one of us is gonna
have to do something horrible um but
back to aquaman
while we wait for that to come in terror
while we wait for that pool to come in
uh it also sounds like they're going to
do
not like an alien movie but they're
going to do like a climate change movie
which
[Music]
money
but i also it's like it's like where's
that money going you little punk i would
love if that's the story of like hey
what uh what are you doing what are you
doing is this captain play on it
i will say one man's trash is another
man's treasure as far as i'm concerned i
keep dumping my own treasure into the
ocean he should be jazzed yeah that's
that's that's perspective
all these dogs from the 90s had to go
somewhere yeah exactly um while we wait
for that poll to complete coy is an
early favorite but black adam director
was talking about sort of hawkman's
complicated origin story in black adam
he goes you know in the comics obviously
there are these clear references uh if
you weren't aware hawkman sort of can
reincarnate so in the comics he says
they're clear references of like hey i
saw you 5 000 years ago remember me he
says they're not going to do that
they're sort of like simplifying the
character's introduction um in how he
reincarnates and all those kinds of
things he says all these rules you don't
want to set those up until the
characters are really established so
he's a very driven character and he
knows that he's on the right side he
says he's a leader he wants to bring
this team together
speaking of the justice society
he wants to bring the team together
bring a certain stability to the world
hawkman has a very strong sense of
what's right or wrong and black adam
challenges that so it sounds like to me
they're gonna just sort of like create
this foil for black adam in this movie
and then worry about all the like power
stuff later where he can reincarnate
they're just going to be like we're just
we're showing you this guy with powers
the hawkman movie will address out there
[Music]
man like i want to see how this hodge it
looks fun i think that i don't want it
heads with the rock yeah well that's the
thing i don't want to see him keep
wasting him not wasting his time i don't
want this to come off as so negative
what i mean waste his time i mean black
adam is coming back and he's going to be
like i'm not going to listen to you like
i'm too busy needing to
redeem everybody we all were slaves at
one point let me just go crazy so i just
want hawkman to be like
god he's just gonna go off the rails
he's just gonna go up the rails
uh okay we're gonna take a quick break
we're gonna be talking about she-hulk
and spider-man in a second but coy uh
koi one coin and you know i gotta say
screw all of you
i really wanted to smash eggs on my head
if i don't get the opportunity to do
that i'm gonna be very upset koi eggs or
mystery box yeah i'm gonna go mystery
box that way when the egg smashing
happens you're you're you're all right
you got it you're good give me enough
eggs
for him he's gonna get there you guys
don't know but the eggs are under john's
butt right now
he's got some eggs
i think he's a bird okay so i punch
through yeah you punch whatever's in it
you have to eat it could be good could
be bad
okay you can't you can't fondle it no
i'm gonna get a sense
it's like the johnny carson thing like
okay this one's the most sparkly that's
actually what decided to see there's
actually sparkles on this one the first
one looks sparkly to me but okay
okay shut up
sparkle
okay
oh reach in there did you get
a box
eat the box
oh a green pepper hello oh it's a
jalapeno oh my god oh god oh no
oh no do you have a drink you have a
drink i got a drink so people that were
uh wanting egg and i assume disappointed
and this is way worse
i like spice don't love the whole
jalapeno i think just eat one bite maybe
wow
you want the full thing i mean look i
don't make the rules here
yeah
we get out of the chat it's a kindness
it's them to em you gotta eat it well i
don't know man
thank you to stephanie horton who says
that they voted for me baby baby baby
that's good enough for me that's good
enough for me
while you deal with that uh at least
we'll have koi on camera while i go
through some of these oh i smell it
eyes are watering marvel animation
producer brad winderbaum
said uh that's right it is hot teased
some future sort of like marvel animated
series and kind of implied that future
marvel animated shows would be taking
place in their own separate universes
right we got that with what if obviously
taking place in a lot of different
universes
um seems like spider-man freshman year
is now going to be earth 616. this sort
of made me think that
it's possible x-men 97 will will not
necessarily be in the continuity
yeah can you tell us can you tell us
what universe these projects are going
to take place in here's what the quote
says he goes here go to camera three go
to camera three please and keep going
that's the wrong camera
we have them labeled wrong in the studio
did what you asked all right
he says what the multiverse do you want
to read this quote you read it
well the multiverse doesn't it allows us
to look at alternate paths and other
takes on the characters which is of
course what happens in the comic books
has different artists different writers
different storytellers work with
characters you see them expanding and
growing in unforeseen unexpected ways
and that's something that is our guiding
light as we make more animated projects
here's the thing while you were reading
that quote
my eyes started to water it is very it's
very pungent there are much more
this is a very this is a different oh
it's not just a casual jalapeno like i
dove in look this is an experience yeah
the rest of that is probably pretty mild
if you want to finish it anyways uh no
you don't have to
have it on your eyes real quick
um hey here's a weird one guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 star will poulter
playing adam warlock debunked a rumor
that i had never heard of but it was
making the rounds and we wanted to fill
you in because that's what we do here um
he was doing an interview and the
interviewer was sort of lobbying fan
theories at him and one of the fan
theories he was proposing was gamora and
adam warlock being love interests yeah
aren't they together in the comics for a
brief point i'm looking at you because i
think they were coy says two spices and
i also think i did a rogue theory this
was like my second rogue theory so it
was yeah
it was your fault
maybe for like an arc but i don't know i
think it was like it was really brief
it's unfamiliar now that you've said it
but i wouldn't have pulled that myself
because i remember when i brought it up
and was like yeah in a comic i read
recently gamora now morlock and people
were like no star-lord and i was like
okay i didn't say that this was the
movie i said this was in a cup and then
you got married i'll say this adam uh
adam warlock and style are not going to
get together no no
i don't think adam warlock i don't think
gamora and starland will end up together
in this film no no no i think this is
the new tyler's bisexual look what
happened i'm going to get some more
i'm going to get some water we're going
to make it worse
anyways gamora is not gamora
that's right he said uh his response to
this question his response to this
question was huh
and then said that would be breaking
news to him it's probably best to assume
that they are not love interests in the
film while we wait for koi i want to
talk about uh something we like to do in
the show which is sort of like talk
about a little biography on some new
people joining the mcu in our
fresh-faced fridays segment sponsored by
geology it's friday and that means it's
time for one of our most special
segments i already set it up but it's in
the prompter anyways uh this is a
segment where we put a spotlight on an
up-and-coming actor in a big project
that you might not be as familiar with
today's fresh face is dominique thorne
got a wonderful image of her she's
playing riri williams aka iron heart in
black panther wakanda forever and
she's apparently she's 25 badass i don't
have i don't i don't have that in my
notes but she's going to be in ironheart
we saw some dope set photos of her the
other day super excited
just wanted to shout her out she doesn't
have a ton of credits so uh but she was
in if beale street could talk the
excellent barry jenkins film which you
should check out if you haven't seen it
and judas and the black messiah which is
an excellent um
uh who directed that film what's her
name
in watchman
or something like that but both academy
award-winning movies yes both academy
award-winning movies should be bringing
a lot of uh incredible talent to the mcu
can't wait to see her in iron heart um
and hey look here's the thing if you're
coming to hollywood and you want to get
your start you need to run around uh you
run around with it with a beautiful face
like koi
uh red right now and that's where our
friends at george
that's where our friends at geology come
in they make excellent skincare product
products and you can take a quick quiz
at geology.com and they'll suggest the
perfect lineup of skincare items for you
so head to geology.com and use our promo
code rockstar 70 to save 70 off on a 30
day trial and you too can have hollywood
skin that's not their tagline i made
that up um you can exfoliate with
jalapenos like koi
you shouldn't do that
you shouldn't do that pour it out do we
want to talk about she-hulk no do we
want to talk about what if we what if we
said no
no
no usually uh tommy or zach do a segway
that's like jessica are you ready
do you even want to talk about it we're
the pretty ugly people that's why whoa
sometimes
we just have to be here yeah we would
love to use geology it seems like great
product we might not need it what's
there i could never go yeah it could be
maybe but maybe
uh so recently spider-man wasn't allowed
to appear in disney places
uh they said uh jessica gao said the
head writer creator said this one uh the
one mcu character that really bummed out
all the writers in our room that we
couldn't use was spider-man and anyone
evolved around like in the spider-man
universe and um like it kind of makes
sense
we can try to piece together theories of
like why would make sense why wouldn't
it make sense uh but what could that
even look like like i i understand
putting it seems like you can't get both
right you couldn't get daredevil and
spider-man you probably would just get
one it would make sense to get both
because then it would show that like
maybe
uh daredevil is not now defending peter
parker and he has to go to she-hulk
maybe that could be the reason but what
could this have looked like if uh picked
between the two
oh god oh god i don't think sparkling
water is going to make it better so the
tricky thing is is i was doing a juice
cleanse it's the first thing i've eaten
in 25 hours so
the heat is just lighting my stomach
because
i have no solid food look what you've
done i wanted eggs so like it's
literally just like it's all liquid and
then heat
there's like a stew in there okay oh
okay all right you're gonna breathe fire
by the end of this episode
i don't know daredevil or spider-man
this is gonna be bad because people i i
would prefer spider-man look
i i don't know if that's a hot take i
know like some people are starting to
get feel over saturated with spider-man
but like i can't i can't get enough of
that character i understand
it but like you
i think i don't know we're probably not
the same thing i was like i think we
might have the same take i think i
understand wanting spider-man but just
like in the future plans and where
daredevil is going it would make more
sense to put him in this she-hulk series
because echo's coming and then born
again is coming versus spider-man's just
nothing right now well and we can talk
about that right we're assuming it's
like a sony
rights problem
but like i i this is a little inside
baseball so i apologize if you if you
get bored hearing this but uh we had
sort of heard that like
marvel uh studios and and disney could
use spider-man in television projects
and that's why they were doing
spider-man freshman year
um
and and this makes it sound like you
know we've also heard in the past that
like
uh marvel says like hey you actually you
can't use that character anyway you want
to because we have plans for them i
could see it being a situation where
like they know exactly what they're
going to do with spider-man character
especially after no way home ended with
like no one knowing who peter parker is
um they might have just been like we we
don't want to like get that whole
situation mixed up in this show because
we know exactly where we want to go with
spiderman i would also argue that in
addition to where they ended with
spider-man you need the opposite for
daredevil right yeah we've introduced
daredevil 100 very lightly now we need
to introduce what the mcu is going to be
doing they're taking their double and
that ties into that more comedic element
so
i think personally using him here is
going to allow for his 18 episode show
to be more 18 episodes mixed in its tone
because we've met him now comedically
because if you look at the mark wade
comics you look at the brand michael
bendis comics there's a lot of comedy
and narrative and everyone online right
now that's like ah everyone marvels
jokes comic books are funny not all of
them but daredevil comic books are often
funny so actually i think you need this
tone that actually leads into my next
part where the head writer jessica gao
also mentions daredevil won't be as dark
as he was in his netflix show but only
in she-hulk here's the quote it was so
fun to be able to take him from the
environment that you know him from which
is much more dramatic and
action-oriented role much more on the
serious side and we bring him into our
world and he gets to play in the tone of
she-hulk we get to see a lighter side of
that character so i think the gateway
drug is the show yeah
i tell you this
put it in my mind
thc daredevil
wow
matt strapped me up put me in the od all
right
but are you excited for daredevil to be
coming i am excited because i i was a
fan of the the original um charlie cox
series on on netflix and him in the
defenders and i am excited to see how
exactly marvel further introduce him
into the mcu with these disney plus
shows and probably future uh mcu movies
it would have been nice to see
spider-man yeah you know
go toe-to-toe maybe or have his quippy
puns with jessica walters in the
she-hulk series but you know i we have
seen a lot of spider-man in the last
five years exactly and charlie cox was
saying that like he's got a he could be
good for the next eight i remember what
the quote was remember he said like i
could be good the next eight years with
marvel with everything we've got lined
up yeah and then like i think that this
is a great way to set up a major player
in new york in this world and i love
spider-man he's my guy but
i think it's really important we let
spider-man be
on a walkabout for a bit because the way
it ended i want spider-man to come back
and be more like the 80s comic books i
want spider-man to be you know up
against all odds he's the true underdog
it took six movies to get spider-man to
his origin that felt like the comic
books we just got power and
responsibility he shouldn't have friends
right now he shouldn't be a comedic
element he's gonna obviously be comedic
when he's spider-man but peter parker's
gone through a lot where's
netflix daredevil i think is the best
marvel adaptation to date i think the
the daredevil show is the best thing
that feels like the comic books now
we've got to figure out how we're going
to balance that tone with the mcu's tone
to make this new 18 episode series work
i think sheila is a great way to do it
and i have a video coming out on sunday
on this exact situation of what
daredevil is going to be doing in
she-hulk and how we're setting him up
for either the thunderbolts echo and
everything else yeah john really likes
it i can get
because i don't get into it in the video
i love i love okay okay watch jessica's
video it's coming out on sunday i love
it a lot um my favorite little little
little connection that you made was you
know jennifer walters is um
is representing abomination in the show
and trying to get him off and and
jessica in the video was like
what if
by mistake
like somehow val is working with this
law firm and jen is getting people off
to go work with the thunderbolts i love
that oh that is fantastic
so good
that's great i love that idea i would it
would uh if we want to be set up for the
thunderbolts that is probably the best
way and you can still involve kingpin
because he could be underneath one of
those
people those roster um
there's a lot of theories in there
that one was john's favorite and um i
like it too i just didn't get too into
it and i'm sorry i should have but
it comes around we're gonna have fun
because like you and i have so much dark
avengers thunderbolt stuff and then you
guys have the mcu knowledge so comic
knowledge mcu knowledge it's gonna be
really fun to see how people feel about
certain characters adaptations what
surprises us versus what surprises
everyone else i'm excited i love it i
see people in the chat talking about
romance and i just want to say this
before we even end uh my discussion is
that i am never in my life
never
especially in the mcu going to ship
she-hulk and spider-man
oh that doesn't make anything ever and
we better not be talking about that i'll
[ __ ] do it
no i'll shoot spider-man and deadpool
before i ship [ __ ] yeah i went home
i put spider-man
i'm shipping both spider-man and
she-hulk with me
there's a lot of spandex yeah yeah yeah
exactly uh but
i do feel like the show's gonna awaken a
lot of people
oh i feel like there's gonna be a
certain like step on me tick-tock trend
i'm excited for the people to get a
little
exist generations uh the mummy i hope so
just a nice bisexual awakening like a
knight's tale the mummy that was that
error and now it's time people you need
to get into the charlie cox
marvel's getting a little too gay
uh
we need to dial it
um no i won't but i'm gonna smash an egg
on my head
for that comment yeah
do you want to smash it can i smash it
on you you can smash it on my head i'm
gonna roll a dice and choose no i'll get
i'll get it i'll get it i'll get it and
give it to you i'll get it and give it
to you oh my god i'm gonna roll i'm
gonna roll the dice
okay i have five is that like the fifth
one in the they're numbered off oh
they're already numbered okay
don't die shuffle legs it's like you
guys playing this what a friday night
going forward i finally what are you
doing i can feel my face what are you
doing
they're numbered why would you grab one
smash it smash it smash it smash wait
wait wait i should get on this camera
wait
it's on one one's fine no no no no give
me give me in here give me all right
well no because i don't want you get on
eric's shirt no do it do it do it no
it's a nice shirt
it's very cold oh it's beautiful
i'm so glad i moved let me go
stay there so let me use your paper
towels let me get your paper that's
projected yeah no i'm glad i moved this
what i would have got
i'm sorry baby it's on your shirt
oh my god okay uh take this for your
eyes
okay okay wait we have a show to do we
have a show to do will val cameo in
oh god look put it in the poles
it's a goddamn goddamn mess
put it in the damn balls
all right all right i'm ready i'm ready
i'm back i'm back it's on your own
that's fine i'll deal with it i'll deal
with it he'll do it live
uh no chickens were harmed in the making
of this episode of the break room
um
jeez us christ
also there's like a two second delay
inherent to like the filming versus and
so i heard it a second and then i saw it
and it was weird like
i
that's fair
but i am curious right like we we
sorry just looks like i'm trying to move
on
but you know what i'm interested in i
want to
here's my question the writers wanted
spider-man what is the spider-man
storyline that got cut i think what i
genuinely think it was i think it's
because uh in the comics one of my
favorite parts is the fact that i told
you get a paper towel in the comics i
really like that devil and spiderman are
friends so if we did start that
relationship in she-hulk of them
becoming friends or they're already
friends um he would be like as a lawyer
i'm a person of not interest what is it
uh lawyer lingo like he can't interfere
with his client that way if peter parker
is like attorney client privilege i
guess yeah but i guess it's like he
doesn't know that peter parker spiderman
so whatever
yeah right yeah your lawyer can't get
involved with you during
like yeah like if they're doing that i
just follow the story with spider-man
and have it be like hey we are all not
remembering something about you what
like why do we all half know you how do
you know there might be a fun thing to
do with like hey you're an avenger why
don't any of us know who you are well it
wouldn't hurt to start it uh when
everyone found out right like
what
my my little bald spot
it was just like extra moist
can we just get cameras
will this grow my hair
vitamins and minerals
i do like that i think that's really
interesting um i am i'm wondering too if
like uh you know it has it would have
had any sort of like um relation to
the uh you know matt murdock
representing him in no way home and if
they were like using that case as an
example well he definitely i don't wanna
i know that peter parker is a silly dumb
boy but he caught that brick through a
wall backwards like he definitely i'd be
like okay you're a super you're a
superhero and they probably definitely
engage in vigilante crime fighting and
he's like well you're still on trial for
this peter parker would know daredevil
but matt wouldn't remember peter parker
right well we're saying if this is after
if it's taking time during he hasn't
already got his mind wiped out
daredevil at the bottom of the statue of
liberty being like you guys need any
help
[Music]
[Laughter]
um i can grow something up to you all
right i'm a very good
yeah baby have you guys seen that video
where it was originally a snow globe the
the brick was actually a snowball and if
you look at it he actually is holding it
like out not like this yeah like they
they change it to a bricklayer what is a
snow globe staying
tech well it was like a mysterio
it was like a mysterio play right
because i need the science facts
also that shows how well daredevil
adjust for inertia that's the skill of a
very good lawyer
that's right
i want a lawyer that can physically
fight yeah yeah speaking of physically
fighting uh my body's been physically
fighting me all week
but thanks to
thanks to
our sponsors for this week athletic
greens while i go grab the product
that's hiding from me like scrambled
eggs no
i'll pick it up
cooking under the lights folks no need
for a complicated cocktail of costly
concoctions just a little copy of a.g in
your tummy will get you feeling healthy
wealthy and wise i wonder who wrote this
copy or at least
it will be like convenient insurance to
make sure you get all the good stuff you
need in a day
to make it easy
and we love things that are easy
athletic greens is going to give you a
free one-year supply of a moon a moon
supporting oh we're all cows today
immune supporting vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com
break room again that is
athleticgreens.com break room to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
if we reach 500 goal uh 500 in the super
chats today i will break one of the raw
eggs into a cup of athletic greens and
drink the whole thing you should just
smash all the eggs i'll also smash the
rest of them on my head guys we're
halfway to a big show
good god
also another 75 and we get to see if
eric or i can oh god
coy and i are still in the polls so you
know
[Laughter]
million scoville gummy bears like cat
challenges and stuff this was obviously
not close to that this has the same
stomach like oh my god
i'm a double i think there's something
up with that house
yeah this is serious
and i love jalapenos you guys we've been
asking you questions in the chat oh yeah
uh we've been asking you questions in
the chat we want to get to them uh some
people are dumb
uh and 26 of you uh said
26 of you said aquaman 2 is going to be
funnier than shazam and that is insane
that is flatly wrong watch it be
hilarious i mean i would love it i would
watch jason
it's just going to be more squidward
it's going to be all him improvising
if we get a little crossover with my man
the deep you know anything does
oh that would kill for an aquaman deep
combo film disgusting um which guardian
would you like to see an iron groot
style mini series 4 39 of you said
rocket that's a little bit of cheating
we got rocket in the i am groot series
um uh 28 of you said mantis that's
surprising only nine percent
said star-lord
um
all right and he was kind of like a
loser when he was a little kid his mom
died and all that stuff
running into fields oh my god
okay
will val cameo and she-hulk a landslide
yes 90 of you said yes that i i mean
people are on board jessica with the
theory i would love it i love it i'm
very i it's more so up to you guys have
decided not to as ever everybody in the
mcu fan base of whether you want them to
go from she-hulk to echo she helped the
thunderbolts or she-hulk to um
uh born again uh uh daredevil born again
it's it's it's there can't be too many
there can't be too many cameos it can't
be like all three shows will start
winning this show is going to be a cameo
fest do you think so yeah i think
they're good
i think
the writers i think gow and the writers
were just like they just like dug up an
old box of comics from the basement of
marvel studios and they were like this
one's weird let's put that one well i
think
they can't ever
i don't think these cameos are going to
get their own series
you don't want a frogman series you're
tripping
i think we're going to see who gets
trending and we're going to get some new
additions themselves
they're gonna be like this guy mt won't
stop tweeting at us
they're really like frogman getting the
show
it's just the program
you guys you know what time it is
tommy's out jessica's in baby it's time
for my mandatory let's go
play my graphic desk
oh thank you
the graphics so nice i'm going to make
you play it twice
play it again quieter oh thank you so
much and because uh rest in peace eric
voss play for a third time oh my god i
didn't even rhyme
oh i don't need to make him wrong i'm
not tommy
man me and my husband are two different
people play it one more time just one
more subtle subtly you have a husband
it's honored oh gross
[Music]
did you guys not know how we worked
together oh i don't marry t-bek totally
he's a monster but he's great in bed
what tommy lacks in nothing i make up in
everything
but i like to get to the nitty-gritty of
my problematic friends especially these
three and the best way to find out which
one of y'all is nasty and which one of
y'all is nasty is it a little game i
like to call red flag green flag
everyone go ahead and grab one of each
one green flag one red flag if you guys
remember in the chat
uh red flag green flag and for we've
we've all played quiz blade right i
don't know oh no okay here we go uh so
i'm going to say a prompt out loud and
you'll hold up a red flag meaning
a red flag meaning no no thank you turn
around stop absolutely not or sorry i
couldn't find the trash can i'm putting
on a chair
we'll clean up later um or you'll do a
green flag for it's good good time go
yep uh give me more
great description so there you go good
good good give me more give me more so
go ahead in the chat if you guys want to
agree with us put your emojis for green
any green emoji you got any red emojis
you got when you disagree or agree with
what we got to say
so let's let
john that egg on his head has ruined him
no such thing as a red flag oh my god
and then also on top of that you guys
are gonna count to three i'm gonna say
one two two three and then you lift your
flag in the air okay okay so keep your
flags down i guess i'll scroll oh i'm so
sorry
you got distracted by that red flag
okay made a meal of it you love them
your entire life but they turn out to be
a scroll you love them
no you were the first one to say yes
you love them your entire life but they
turn out to be a scroll ready
one
two three
oh
hell yeah baby
no it's just kinkier that way oh yeah
i'm not speciesist no i think it's fine
well i think the the hard thing is i
brought this up to my mom on my way here
and she said i don't trust someone that
laughs
did they ever say inherently they
weren't a scroll
[Applause]
this [ __ ] yeah
she never said that she killed someone
a lot of greens in the chat as well a
lot of greens in the chat also the
opportunities there are infinite oh yeah
i'm just saying like then i find out i'm
like returning to shannon's assassin
tonight okay
we've always wondered what it would be
like to have sex with yourself
very bad yep
the low-key thing like the female me i'd
find that the heartbeat
he's an art collector
and wants to make a new and better
neighborhood for us all you guys this
person is an art collector and wants to
make a new and better neighborhood for
us all
one
i'm going to start throwing hands one
two
three
i'm confused
this is wilson fisk
and oh he's the rick caruso of his
promise yeah and you put a green up my
dudes oh that's not
billionaire art collector that changes
things no one is making a hundred
thousand dollars a year collecting art
also no one is collecting art and also
trying to like can buy a neighborhood
you know it's like like that there they
have the
said he's an art collector and wants to
make a better neighborhood for us sounds
like a nice guy he had a very
gentrification aj thank you thank you oh
wait a minute i just want someone to
clean up the homeless problem and kick
all the undesirables out of my
neighborhood sorry i didn't even hear
that but now i can't unhear it and i'm a
monster
who's the pretty people on your show red
flags in the chat now that everyone's
hearing it's [ __ ] refreshing
to change
i was a young boy when i was a young
warthog
he's got a great uh wardrobe i love his
shoulder shirts his shoulder he'll take
me to fao schwartz for a little pick me
up i'm gonna make you an omelette um
okay are you guys ready he's the epitome
of perfection but he's created by the
sovereign he's the uh
i don't even think he's the epitome of
thank you guys for playing the game
however
he's the epitome of perfection but
created by the sovereign one two three
i can't do it what i can't do have you
seen him yeah but it's it's giving off
do you want to say it
it's giving up oh no guys uh
t-1000
okay i'll take that yeah
what's wrong with the epitome of
perfection if everyone's created by
somebody who's the last person that
wanted to do the epitome of perfection
it didn't go well
but this one is different we learned
also you have to deal with the sovereign
dude they would probably nah
me and adam are gonna jet off to a weird
planet no one's ever heard of and have a
great vibe together do i even see the
sovereignty great in bed nope
driving and he's the worst one also no
okay so real talk this is uh uh right
your picture show you're dealing with
rocky just being created yeah but he's
smarter than rocky
well um
i just want to know what the inside of
that man's cocoon looks like that's it
it's just a bunch of pain
adam warlock's the smart guy i trust
what does the shot look like you guys i
did not see is it reds or is it green
it feels like we're spamming emojis that
you guys have to approve of so i'm so
sorry about that okay another one
he's a vampire that can walk in daylight
fight for you but wants to suck your
blood he's a vampire that can walk in
daylight fight for you but wants to suck
your blood
one
two
three
sorry blade i got it oh it's blade
because i don't trust anyone i thought
it was that guy that's been selling time
shares in
both of those make complete sense anyone
in a long enough timeline that wants to
eat you guys the thing is he really
wants to suck our blood doesn't mean he
does it yeah he can good on uh you know
with not human blood and you guys won't
i
used to donate blood i got way too much
okay i got way too much that's not what
the kink is you got a problem with adam
warlock but not with someone who's
trying to eat you you love me by eating
he's just sucking some of your blood
yeah i got too much anyway yeah and
we'll also we'll just keep making it
yeah it's a nice reciprocal what if he
has that one taste and he doesn't like
it you know i doubt that's going to if i
have the army hammer's in the chat rod
there's a documentary coming out we're
gonna see all about it here's my
question here's my question for you too
every relationship is about compromise
yeah he sucks your blood what do you get
out of it oh you know what i get out of
it
i get to watch him hunt i'm not biased
i like that you didn't choose the like
sex part
yeah that's what i was sort of asking
about
i mean you play children
oh you're just buddies
[Applause]
that doesn't sound like friends
can we go to the dodgers game today
what's wrong with you nothing nothing
like that someone also said it's just a
sip so i needed to go just a sip
y'all are nuts
that's just eric um okay he's an
all-powerful changer of fate so you
never know what you're gonna get he's an
all-powerful changer of fate so you
never really know what you're gonna get
three
two
one
yup
eric i like consistency i can't i can't
have a randomized he's an all-powerful
changer of fate so you never know what
you're going to get my man you weaponize
that as fast as you can
make my life better please kang i play
girl you can be significantly more it
could be the monkey paw of
interactions look see i like spontaneity
i was just about like everything being
an option not like variety this seems
like it's gonna give me some some
creativity exactly also you know not to
be that person after like a couple years
after a couple times you gotta mix up
also my favorite line from megan the
stallion is switch my wig make him feel
like he's cheating
because this is right there literally
we're getting a lot of greens in the
chat shout out to caitlyn martinez a
frequent super chatter charlie836
uh for saying can we play this game
blindfolded i don't know what that means
uh i'll always be blindfolded if that's
a request td jones for giving us a few
bucks for mandatory fun appreciate all
you guys uh we're gonna get to some of
your stupid chats in a minute but that
did put us over there yeah we're gonna
figure out what it is
uh it wasn't wanda no it was not wanda
sorry that was for kane that's a big
green flag right there if it's wanda
get me a second green flag
i'm leaving
you're like yo she wants to have some
kids and we go make some that's right
i can pretend to be a robot until the
cow's going off
one of our when we played once it was
like uh she's the most powerful sorcerer
she's the most powerful witch but she
has long dark black fingertips and john
was like put that in
right now
make it happen jessica that was that was
it for my mandatory fun you guys when
tommy's not here we keep it
tight
oh
same day same dude same difference
jessica's winning i'm thrilled
where am i winning in the pool oh god
please don't make me smack it i just
closed out of the teleprompter like a
goon
that's all right here we go we're back
also i like how you were like i picked
up the egg
why yeah that [ __ ] was let's feed it to
a snake i don't know a snake feed it to
a snake they'll have to unhinge their
jaw uh is that what we want to do hey
guys
uh it's friday and what we do what we
like to do on fridays is get to a few
more of your guys super chats just to
thank you for supporting us this week
uh
edward de zeus says i want to see you
guys switch glasses here's the thing i'm
reading super chats
i have i can't see oh
i'm gonna i'm going into my box i'm so
sorry you're doing a box hey you're not
gonna do an egg
if i had to choose i would do the box
like koi because you're you're a wild
one
i feel
i got that oh oh okay close
his are aggressive more aggressive yeah
my eyes are definitely weaker than you
want to see aggressive i wasn't trying
to be mean like that
oh no would you punch that's a puppy
oh
come on she knew it's rigged that's
amazing to eat this
and you just punch the cupcakes
yeah that's another hundred dollars so
we can feed jessica a freaking egg
daschle comes in here and he well i
punched it i don't like my hands getting
messy
i can't read anything on the super chat
board anymore so i'm going to swap those
glasses back i got a bigger head than
you do too i don't want to stretch your
glasses out
um
uh someone named e says love you guys
i'm a sucker for versus battle so my
question for y'all is out of all of the
live-action comic book characters which
two would you all like to see fight one
another i'm gonna say uh universe be
damned it could be a dc marvel mashup it
could be someone not in either of those
two universes coy uh i feel like you've
had this question prepared
my whole life
uh you know i've always wanted to settle
the age-old debate of
batman versus anyone in marvel like i i
think there's always that like with
batman with enough prep he can beat
anybody i would actually like to see a
throw down where there isn't like two
studios behind it and you'd actually see
who wins like batman versus superman is
fun uh i i personally i'd love to see
batman versus deadpool because deadpool
can regenerate over and over again and
does batman just get frustrated that his
plans don't work because homeboy can
just like keep re-existing so batman
deadpool i think is a big one for me but
i also love to see homelander captain
america
i like that um i just want to address
two things in the chat really quick that
i'm reading i don't set the tables
dashboard does
so i'm not cheating in this game
casualness
i don't know tommy and myself are not
actually married
so nina you still have a chance you
still have a chance i don't know uh
i i'm going to do a cop-out answer yeah
it's i really i want to see spider-man
and carnage go head-to-head i really do
um just because that's a comic a comics
think that i really like and i don't
know if we're ever gonna get it yeah
spiderman versus carnage yeah like in a
movie oh the movie yeah yeah he's like
that's available today yeah right now
yeah yeah i've read them
available right now i want alligator
loki and rock jaw
oh that's actually really fun i like
that because lockjaw will it'll just be
both of them zipping like going
like from different places all the time
and him just chasing like the alligator
going
and hissing
i want to see
amanda waller mm-hmm versus nick fury
that's yeah that is good yeah
uh a couple more film juice big fan of
film juices uh he says who else wants a
little wings on their feet like neymar
little baby wings little bitty wings
also don't hurt yourselves with food
today i've got bills to pay i don't know
what that means
i don't expect it rhyming okay i i do
respect it it is monday friday but also
film juice
um i got eggs in front of me this
is no
[Music]
[Music]
into a bottle and add in a raw egg which
have been sitting in chicken no no no no
no don't eat that egg i don't think you
can
you can drink them
i'm gonna put the rest of the eggs
and put the rest of the eggs in my head
honey are you sure
yeah
he's a man of honor this is for dodson
um
uh okay i'm gonna give this to you i'll
be right back do you guys have any other
personal the personal questions you guys
have any other questions we're still in
a horny red flag
jt ty said if you could be any mcu
character why who would it be and why if
i could be if i could be any like in a
movie or in life
like play one or b1 well we're assuming
that in life superheroes are as welcomed
as they are in the movies
keep that in mind uh i think i would be
iron man because he learns how to wield
his power and money and things well by
the end and he's loved and like he's got
an ego and he's a narcissist and those
things feel comfortable to me oh honey i
want to be someone close but also more
successful i've and have a family right
now i've talked about it time and time
again i would love to be harley quinn i
like the idea of being like an agile
super villain uh i like also the idea of
not having like to deal with having the
power powers that like uh poison ivy
would have or anyone else i just like
the idea of being like athletically i
can just jump flip and still crack your
neck with my legs and rock banks and
just rob banks
fairly human like i'd be worried about
being captain america being like uh
trapped out of time i'd be worried about
having certain powers and like breaking
stuff like i like that we're both like i
want to be something i can handle yeah
so then i can and also i doesn't mean i
have to do horribly badly i don't have
to kill everyone every second i would
just be like uh i think we're just going
to take money from this atm yeah you can
do it recreationally
which i do every tuesday yeah yeah what
do you want to be uh i think i would but
then also you uh with harley quinn's
abilities and stuff you'd be a brilliant
psychologist yeah so you guys know that
uh element to be in harlequin i want to
be whiplash
[Applause]
okay i like how you moved yeah smashing
happening oh yeah i think i would be
spiderman
um because
spiderman ooh spiderman john t spiderman
yeah which of these eggs are
you want me to do this one this one you
can just peel it isn't it olive oil
we can just test it well you're putting
one in the shake and then this is one i
hate this why did i say it i i i doubted
the audience we all well
you can't really do it should we take
turns smashing anything's on his head
yes 100. this is awful oh wow this is
terrible well you guys did this too
thank you audience thank you internet
for making this happen
it's going out on a friday very very
strong oh yeah yeah
who's your favorite sad origin story i
want to see i want to see the waynes get
murdered every freaking that's why i
wouldn't want to be because i want my
parents to be alive i love
parents are overrated
i i think daredevil with his dad uh but
also because i'm born again it just
happened again
like it's not i i sorry to like kind of
be lying your statement but like
to have it happen to you like twice
remembering adam's family values when he
gives it to the baby and he goes head in
the pocket
i'm gonna drink it and then smash it and
then we're going to say goodbye to these
lovely people
john is guest on i wish
this is going to suck uh our friends at
athletic green are really going to cover
the taste of the egg here we go fingers
crossed just go do some uh some pull-ups
and push-ups after
you can take two eggs because i already
did one okay all right oh the eggs last
how'd the egg make it in the powder part
wow
he did it we're getting slack messages
which means it's probably philip yelling
what are you turning that channel into
yeah
oh my god champion it i i will say
no it was horrible
all right
and then this is how we're gonna say
goodbye thank you so much for watching
the break room with uh
with us this week um
we love you guys very much
uh you're the reason that we do this
show and you're the reason that i
torture myself oh god um
come back and watch us next week we're
going to be talking about shield
all these lovely people will be here we
have a clip of the week to take us out
although i think it's probably this
goodbye
my secret is
i'm always horny